hello everyone what's up and welcome to
another episode of rent cafe here in
anime uproar I am Anna Mack and I'd like
to welcome you to what is gonna be a
tradition here I think a tank of failure
we're going to be looking at after the
first few episodes of the new season air
we're gonna do our first impressions and
kind of give you an idea of what we
think about the season so far
and that way give you recommendations
for what you should watch or a boy
exactly what you should avoid in this
next season and actually I got a few
comments I forget enough who exactly
commented saying on our last one that we
did on this kind of like you guys have
to do this every season it's very useful
so absolutely we will it's a lot of fun
and we did it for the summer season and
that was fun too so yeah I'm looking
forward to it joining me today we've got
now got up back in the house hey hello
we got Knox Taku back with us after like
three weeks two weeks and Counting
thank you but yeah every time you're
gone you miss you so much yeah I know I
see the comments on your videos waiting
for me I know like Knox is like boys
were just like at every rank of a snob
he tells them he tells them probably
like hey guys where's Knox
OK'd honest truth is they're all they're
all second and third accounts you know
was busy but he's like no no I need Knox
[ __ ] you Thank You nuts for being back
while having you on so much the back as
well you've been busy
you've been busy I can feel it because I
haven't seen you as much on this cord
but you still make time for an cafe
which is good yeah man yeah man yeah
always busy always busy like today was
my daughter's birthday in it yeah happy
birthday to your daughter
Amelia that's that's correct
it's Amelia's birthday yeah that's a
whole new character from terraformers
the one who sends the
dress message I don't know if you guys
seen it well yeah I heard the animes
crap compared to the manga so I just
didn't watch it I don't know but that's
a really gorgeous name yeah obvious
reasons come on let's not destroy you
being a fanboy and I feel like this is
becoming a trend so first impressions
who's best girl I know you know what you
know what guys like why don't we just
get into Knox and recon fighting because
no section everyone comes for busy
what's cool - how's everything going
going good
who the [ __ ] is Miyazaki by the way
right - own in aren't you
it's cool with Rika always always has a
sense of humor about himself which is
why we tolerate him look it's it's a
problem with someone has bad taste but
if they know they have bad taste it
makes it so much better I don't have bad
taste at all I wasn't talking about you
as a general statement ok now we're so
fall are weak we're going in order from
my anime list in popularity right just
to make it more easy make know like it's
up to you guys for example I haven't
seen whole anime I've seen you know 5 or
6 the first few episodes but I'm also
looking forward to recommendations for
what you guys well I watch them missing
out on so alright in the comments let us
know if you know what anime you're
really enjoying what anime you recommend
should be seen what anime should be
avoided at all costs all that kind of
stuff the ancient Maya watch it now
about we get what was once the the most
anticipated anime turned out to be a
completely average so let's just get out
of that let's just get that out of the
way first
what are you talking about black clover
first no I was gonna say no I mean I
don't think that was the most
anticipated no was it to me anyway
a lot of people I anticipated in my
books anyway yeah yes as well so yeah
but no we can start with block over
because it was pretty hyped and the
reason it's hiked is of course it's it's
serialized in the weekly shonen jump
which is always a big thing when one of
these series becomes an anime and also
it's there's a lot of hype around it
because it borrows socco heavily from
some of the biggest and most popular
anime ever and today so for example the
fact that hasta has you know power in a
world with magical powers and then
suddenly gains to the best magical power
in some ways is very reminiscent of my
near academia asta kind of looks like
Naruto let's let's just say it won the
wizard round rather than the pirate king
in one piece but yeah it's like a it's
like the Creator took a bunch of stuff
that he saw worked and put it all
together now
you know everyone borrows from everyone
else that's not a big deal on its own
however so I'm not saying this anime
slash manga couldn't be good but so far
I've seen the first two episodes and
while I don't hate it I certainly like
that the main character is not a huge
crybaby for example the rival is not a
crybaby either I like that much I like
to hold him the hosta hitting on the nun
I'm liking that I hate that hitting on
the nun happy joke ever but then again
I'm not Catholic so I can't relate to
you know if people get offended over
that but to me that's kind of like Hugh
so yeah that's so I like certainly but
I'm not super impressed or anything like
that but I like you guys to give me your
opinions as well the vibe the creator of
this show gives off is he is a huge
shown in fanboy
he just loves Shonen and he's gonna like
make this be shown in you know cliche
because I mean it has everything you've
mentioned it has that underdog
protagonist who gets that power and
whatever but he's also not taking many
things
like I could see how he would have made
you know the rival he would have made
him like a Sasuke or a Baku go you know
edgy whatever angry at the world and
stuff but instead you knows like a good
guy they're rivals because they both
want the same position but he's a you
know normal human being as opposed to
Sasuke and back ago he's not not a
psychopath just in its defense I mean
there is a lot wrong with it but in its
defense it's not a bad show I mean in
the Korea's defense I have to say that
it's not his fault because if you see
his earlier works it was actually decent
but the thing is basically the editors
of jump forced him to make black clover
so blame jump is just the way they're
headed zone I believe he had a earlier
monger old hungry Joker which was
cancelled up like 16 chapters or
something so then he went this I'm just
gonna take a bunch of elements that work
and work with that voice actors decide
because we all know ass does the worst
voice actor ever the main character asta
I think he's more bearable aside from
that than Naruto just in early Naruto
was horrible I mean the character not
the show he was just believing
everywhere and it was terrible leave it
yeah no no but I mean
aster keeps him doing that dumb face all
the time as well I prefer him - no -
Natsu as well I really hated Natsu
something that really needed to happen
not to yes a sense of humor yeah like a
lot of no how the [ __ ] can you compare
hasta to Natsu different than Natsu
though he only had 3 episodes so far so
you're gonna compare him to a character
that already had 500 episodes that's
that's unfair as well alright here's
what I'm gonna say so far not soup is is
is great he's a good [ __ ]
a fantastic character hasta in the other
hand it is so annoying like he is mainly
the main reason that is ruining the show
for me because it is hard for me to you
know watch it while listening to an
annoying voice actor constantly yelling
and screaming almost all the time if he
didn't have an annoying voice would you
like the character like if you had like
a different yeah well I claim the
character yeah well I said voice actor
aside cuz not Sue's voice actors great
his English voice actors great as well
yeah he's already down the line he's
already pretty badass for where he's up
to when the show starts he's already a
pretty powerful wizard whereas hasta
starts at the bottom and we're gonna see
him built up impression on this because
I haven't seen fairytale the only thing
that I've watched from like the
forbidden for was DBZ and because of
course I got into that but I felt right
off the boo see this is a big three in
the forbidden for and the you know five
four but like I just recently now start
a gay into one piece you know I'm like
about to merge onto 100 well you know I
think this need to happen it really
needed to happen because from a lot of
different people's aspects from one side
of the field people think the anime
industry is hurting from the other side
of the field people think that it's
thriving and from the other people on
the side of the field that thinks that's
thriving it's because shows like these
come out and they challenge DBZ one
piece fairy tale they it's literally
challenging all of it because all of you
guys can literally relate to all of
those shows into this one show this is
something that every shown in kid is
wedding is pants over right now I think
this is good no I mean a Gorgons it cuz
I wouldn't say is challenging the other
shows cuz it's just a repeat of the
other shows it is a repeat it is a
repeat yeah so one
because he wizard King no Naruto you
know what I mean if atomic from someone
who hasn't watched Naruto but you guys
can relate to Naruto games knucks I've
played some nartu games like we have
plenty of time to argue recon versus
knocks it's gonna be great but before
that lets you know uh space let's run
into it kind of thing by the way guys
Knox and I were just working on a collab
earlier today that's gonna be on his
channel so that should be interesting a
collab between the two of us a challenge
from lastly yeah look forward to that of
course everyone in here their channel
links are in the description
I just wanna shout out Matt come on he's
in the chat our boy ANBU over there
moderating keeping the peace original
Inc a bunch of other cool folks and it's
interesting because the chat I'm seeing
a lot of stuff in the chat I'm seeing in
terms of black clover some people hate
it some people say it's just man to me
basically
Matt would sum it up like I didn't think
the protagonist was that annoying I
didn't think like it wasn't like jarring
to me like this is crap but it wasn't
also anything unique or anything special
it was kind of like I felt like I've
seen a lot of these things before
even the backstory where you know I
stuck goes and he helps the guy and puts
himself to line to help his friend I
mean all of that has been seen before so
many times with all these showing things
however I do tend to like protagonists
who are not crybabies and who actually
like talk to girls and will actually
like I'm like hit on girl stuff like
that I relate more to that so in that
sense you know someone like it's hard to
really well it's hard to really say I
mean there's three episodes out on a
show that needs at least a hundred to
get going so I mean that's a problem to
me any show that needs a hundred to get
going I think about it yeah Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood has 60 episodes
and it's one of the greatest anime of
all time black oh well this is one
though this is a different this is a
different style than Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood
is a fairy tale style show I mean it's
gonna need a lot of episodes the first
three episodes oh it's Naruto style you
know but either way watch Naruto
something needs to happen early on to
get like viewers interest that's it it
doesn't matter if it's a thousand
episodes or only two something needs to
happen to gain viewers interest that's
what makes it interesting if that don't
happen and it takes a hundred episodes
or two thousand episodes then something
is wrong that's it no one's saying it's
great the same saying it's a new old
style or whatever that's not an argument
okay
I'm not arguing if you look at one piece
one piece took fifty episodes to start
going right yeah I could say I just it
only got good once like we were in the
are long arc and I was like no I can
hour long
yeah hour long oxide fight one episode
for you well at that point it only
started getting really good like smoker
showed up and it got really good I there
were so many times I bawled my eyes out
before hour-long showed up but it was
when I started one piece I dropped it in
episode 24 and it took me years to get
back to it yeah of course it's
preference but I mean I wasn't huge I
mean it gets way better I mean from
episode 200 till like you know till like
seven hundred is unbelievable the reason
why I'm saying that I like think black
clover is like it needs to happen like
it's good because so many of you guys
can
late to this anime because it is copying
off all of the Shonen anime that
everybody grew up with so now you've got
millenials old agers everybody now is
watching this and they're really getting
there they're comparing it in a very big
way as well I just feel like something
like this needs to happen and needs to
get big because then that's something
new for everyone else to latch on to
that's a new style of anime a newer
style and you can get the old like old a
new crowd and kind of back into it I was
considering making a video sort of what
you're talking about because ever since
Fairy Tail
there wasn't any new breakthrough shown
and to get kids into it and whatever I
mean there were things like you know
sorted online attack on Titan but they
were like small shows in comparison
until my hero academia came which was
amazing at the start at least as far as
shonan's go and I think that's really
what pushed black clover to become an
anime so quickly because it was only
after season 2 started they were like
holy crap we have to make like over a
thing and I think more of these are
gonna start popping up because since
Fairy Tail there was like a depression
we'll see because I could see black
people were being like I could see it
succeeding but I could also see it not
because I like a lot of the comments
I've seen there's been hype about it in
terms of there's a lot of expectation
for it but then there's also a lot of
this doesn't live up to hype it's just
average right so I don't know if it's I
don't think it's guaranteed to succeed
no it's not you know you never know
whose arrow might get bored after like
eight episodes and say screw it we're
gonna make him the king no I mean its
episodes long it's a long runner it's
gonna be a long-running show so I would
say give it a few more episodes just
give it a chance to see how it's gonna
improve a few more Souls and also we
have to see what the ratings are gonna
be like right like if people are gonna
actually be tuning in both in Japan and
outside your fan which I think that they
do track right so they will know and
what isn't
by the way shout out to all day anime
and the charity was supposed to join us
today but then last minute couldn't for
some reason no no
happened but yeah also Timo Van Buren
any relation to Armin van Buuren the
king of Tron holy crap mind blown she
wants to talk about what evening we have
Shiki so if I don't want to talk about
English she okay well if you want I can
start on that I was gonna talk about
something else next but na Yoshiki I
didn't really like why I first of all
I'm not a fan of the three what's it
called the animation damn it
whatever CGI garbage it wasn't terrible
it's not as bad as I June or Knights of
Cydonia but it's not special at all
and I can't relate to sixty year old guy
with cancer that became Deadpool
personality I mean the thing what the
thing what I liked about this the first
episode is because it really was
completely sad it almost I almost cried
I felt so bad for the old man having to
know that he had stomach cancer and none
of his family cared about what he has to
say that is what really almost made me
cry until one day he a bright lights
eyes was guy aliens just took him
completely dis redesigned his body and
now he he's not gonna die anymore he's
invincible cyborg
sounds like crap I mean me to be alright
I've never seen anything like this it's
it's completely brand new to me so I'm
like this is interesting I'll definitely
keep on watch well I'll stick with it
for a few more episodes but from the
get-go I did not get impressed and I
didn't feel sad at all because maybe I'm
more cynical and I'm watching it the
whole time I'm like okay how could I not
be sad depressive yotz
let's see some people just don't cry
over that stuff some people like that's
not anime that pushed me to tears a
little bit at least whereas this one
really didn't at all I was like okay
fine he's an old guy knocks cries a lot
during one piece I can confirm this I
cry a lot during one piece I'm not gonna
lie
and price is not a dude are you getting
this from but it's like I don't want
well have you guys quite over boat
though
don't give too much away I'm on like
episode 97 oh you don't know about
I'm freaking out oh okay well really bad
like this is the best anime this is
gonna be the best I promise you guys I
hope you don't mention the one I was
gonna say no I was gonna call you didn't
mention mine good whew
why wait what was it again the agent
yeah you need to watch the OVA is first
off I did this is one that people are
talking about but I haven't gone into it
oh my god I promise okay I don't think
it's gonna be the best but I do think
that's a character writing on ta the
female protagonist is the best character
writing I've seen I don't really know
him yet this is why you're going to love
it this is her story and his goal yes
yes the story and the goal and the fact
that they have literally figured out a
way to take every genre that everybody
really loves and connects with and just
add a little splash of it with all
different kinds of personalities and the
artwork from going from manga because
manga artwork was [ __ ] breathtaking
and they made it to anime and they just
it's breathtaking a [ __ ] animation is
also very beautiful it's attack on Titan
studio I know I know they do great all
right well I'll take your word for it
I'm making a whole video on episode 1 so
I know
your review but I'm not gonna do it
until episode six no I'm sorry I'm gonna
do until ten since there's 24 commend
you doing it on the first OVA cuz I hope
you set your right no you're right you
are the beginning you need to start that
but I'm not doing it my my review is on
the character writing if Qi say it is
not on the actual anime oh it's it's
it's just comparing that to other great
character writings and I think that hers
is amazing I will really get into that
video subscribe yeah I should hire you
to do that nice not very different ideas
about videos and he's always hustling so
definitely take huge respect for Knox um
by the way summer philosopher into Chad
said earlier you know when we're talking
about you know anime grabbing you on the
start he mentioned Code Geass grabbing
you right off the bat I have to agree
also
Death Note second episode you're like oh
my god this is amazing so yeah I
definitely think absolutely this first
episode yeah attack on Titans first
episode is unbelievable how they wrote
through the whole episode from hit as
far as his perspective and as far as how
this tangible fear will be throughout
the entire series and just didn't see no
his mum being and the ending scene just
lingers in your head waiting for next
week what my favorite anime this season
so far and no one's talking about it at
all it's called and it's a terrible name
children of the whales oh and if you see
it yes right so I'm calling it best
anime of the season aside from maybe my
host guy because I don't know it's not
really best but it has a lot of
potential it is definitely good as
potential about I wouldn't say best in
my opinion okay so with it what's wrong
with it it does everything I know
nothing's wrong with it but I wouldn't
say it is the best so better I called
Maiden abyss as best and
last season after I watched the first
episode for the same reason as this
basically just as far as the story
writing and character writing and world
building this this got it down in the
first episode and it's only going to
develop from here I guarantee it
so why did why did I hear somewhere
someone say that shoulder of the whales
was weird
it is weird but that's what makes it
it's weird in a fantasy way it's a whole
different universe with a completely
different you know rulebook than
anything you've seen I'll have to check
that out
thinking it's weird and some sort of
like incest lolly where there's no
incest or lollies or anything like that
and yet none yet you never know there is
actually a lolly girl in there so yes
yeah because like six what it does not
count are when they're like oh she's 22
years old yeah yeah yes so agent Mac
Magus bride I need to check that out
then because I haven't been in the loop
for that and Cheryl the way also the
other two that sound like ones I need to
watch personally so far the one I'm
enjoying the most is quino's journey or
key no no Tommy because I watched the
original series and I really liked it
because it's a really it's one of those
weird series that it's like it's not
supposed to be realistic but it's
supposed to teach you things about life
and every episode teaches you that life
is both beautiful and cruel at the same
time I would like that I saw the first
two episodes of it and it did impress me
to be honest but I can see how it
wouldn't be like a draw for many many
viewers like a lot of people first of
all a lot of people don't want slice of
life and what it is life though and when
people do want a slice of life thank you
recon yes is it it's you very often you
want comedy or romance something more
like that than an actual you know
adventure anime looking at different
societies and how they work
and I like it but it is mostly are you
before you to you I don't know you don't
remember because you're laying it just
like you just jump in no I am the
transition no no you can't come you out
this isn't the Oscars bro this is my
show alright but anyway as I was saying
I don't I wouldn't say that
keno no Tommy is slice-of-life sure but
it's episodic in the sense that she
visits different societies and these
societies have different rules and
cultural norms which actually ask
questions about human society and you
know what would you do is where murder
is not illegal
you know what would that do to humanity
what would that you know how would we
react if we were in that situation and
it's an interesting philosophical anime
so yeah I think it's I really appreciate
it's never gonna be a mainstream type of
anime no and I also think that the
animation is good because it's updating
original but it isn't like over-the-top
CGI weird stuff so I do appreciate that
as well well the first episode of Kim's
journey was mostly slice-of-life because
it was mostly focused on Kido and his
cocky motorcycle for almost the entire
episode the second episode as well uh
that's not really what happened the
second episode the second episode was
mostly also filled with action because
we saw keno an action a well this
[ __ ] revolver literally everyone
first of all I think he knows a girl
really give up yes boxing just because
there's action it doesn't make it less
slice-of-life ways of life just means
every episode you could just come in at
any time you can enjoy the end I mean
and that's how it is if you'd have
watched episode 2 before episode 1 you'd
have had the same exact you know idea of
the anime like a second late so I so
life is personal you can be and you're
fine with it every episodes its full is
a full narrative but that's just
episodic that doesn't mean
like you can have your boy bebop is
episodic it's not a slice-of-life anime
exactly yeah yeah because they're not
about a slice in his life as much as
this is about Kino because Kino I mean I
don't know maybe about being able to
relate your own personal normal life to
it slice of life means your own normal
if their life is traveling through space
shooting asteroids that might be a slice
of their life but it's not a slice of
life trapped again everyone's gonna do
that in their life I just got it and he
knows the girl have you guys seen evil
or live well no yes I have it's very
good I like it
is it good I haven't seen it but I'm
very very excited as I know I heard
terrible reviews terrible terrible I
mean it is mostly prison survival so
yeah I mean anything grated less than a
six on my anime list run okay look
listen just give it a go I beg you just
give it a go just I'm going to the
reviews the reviews because I have recon
just watch the first episode ducts
change your mind every episodes 20
minutes I mean 20 series 20 minutes of
you damn it come on they will save any
how many of you guys checked out girl
vanishing line yeah I like I like Garo
vanishing line it's basically it's like
bleep this is coming from someone who
hasn't launched bleach okay I think you
froze yeah yeah Anna Mack is now why not
Joe is lagging out yeah
all right carry on people
how about we talk about GE best hat like
this season which is both no wait let me
let me stop and take a breath cuz it
looks like he's not breathing
Anna back fix your internet yeah what if
he's like a now he's probably getting
more we're saying on delay as well
alright so I guess it's time to continue
okay how about we talk about the BOSU
ball get left behind man yeah so Anna
Mack will continue we'll get back to
your discussion later we still love you
okay I'm going to hope that yeah how
about we talk about boku no kanojo okay
we have to listen I thought I literally
thought there was no harem this season
which was disappointing but then I know
I saw you was well yeah until you told
me and I was like yes a savior has come
so I did watch it and I'm caught up and
I must say I am impressed it is very
good of course is good she's she's very
good yes what do you see in any of the
characters in that show when I mean when
when he asks for a picture of her cuz
she's his girlfriend now
I know oh can you send me a picture of
you she's like sure she sends him a
picture for him to jerk off at okay
that's what I know about that is what
made me laugh you even showed me that in
the bond already so I I think he's back
she is she is basically a beginner so
she just wants to learn what love is so
yeah I think the things that guys like
in yeah we can hear you now we can he
know we can hear you no we can't no
still still lagging and I'm alright I
get oh we have another animatic it's
just clone i what the hell yeah too
it's a glitch yes it's a clone no kanojo
that we needed to Duke we move on please
no we still have legs
no lollies after the Armageddon I'm
going to a copy and paste something into
the chat because I can't pronounce it
and if I pronounced it I'm going to
embarrass myself don't worry that's the
best that's what I was saying that's the
lollies in the Armageddon is that what
it is lollies in the arm I don't know if
that's what it's called that's what I
call it that looks really interesting
so that's basically about these two like
the cutest people ever like these cute
little mush balls oh is that my white
fox yeah
and they basically they're in a world
that civilization was already seemingly
destroyed and they're surviving and it's
like it's weird mix of sombre and like
cutesy it sort of has a maiden of this
vibe vibe just because it's such a
traumatic setting but it's not bad it's
not nearly as good as Maiden abyss but
it's not bad it is a slice of life it's
cute it's cute that's what make me
watching I love the character design as
good as made in abyss yeah it is chibi
is it it's like chibi style so it
shouldn't be that good but the
characters are cute I like it I like the
scene where they took a bath together
that's all in here about yeah can we go
back to the vanishing line
yeah yeah like I was saying I like it
because it's like bleach into the
concept of like hollows or pores
whatever but we got like a badass
Ghost Rider type dude in like a samurai
suit and like some interesting
characters in there so I like the first
two episodes I've seen the first
episodes and I liked it the setup and
the characters and stuff and yeah yeah
it has something that's some some cool
factor
that makes me want to stick around is it
related to the other Garro series no it
is
completely new coz that's why I didn't
watch it I didn't like the original ones
oh there it is I just found it that does
look really interesting it looks like
what is it
wetland you know art why isn't it yeah
red line or what's the first Garo that
was very good the second one was it was
just terrible I just did not enjoy the
second one there's no one what you hold
it yet then I have and despite a lot of
people saying it's pretty not so good I
think it's not bad I feel like it could
become something decent you know with
enough episodes but I caster for life
says that the main character Goro is the
most manly dude ever no that's not right
because compromise the most manly dude
ever
but I get your point this guy is manly
as hell and I like them oh yeah watch a
pro Samurai have you anemic
there is no Afro Samurai yet oh gosh
okay I think I watched a long time ago
but it wasn't anything particularly
interesting to me it's a vengeful story
very cliche a vengeful story and um by
now I'm not saying you lost the
challenge of saying you lost that part
so what would you choose would you
choose to watch UQ holder or black cover
you mean to be long-running no no to
watch like if both of them were on right
now what one would you choose torch
I would watch you key holder okay I
don't have any draw two black clover I
don't feel anything towards it at this
point okay okay I mean there are a bunch
of other stuff that a lot of people
aren't talking about anyone watch Osama
game no good yes I watch it it's not bad
it's not bad I think every character
every single one it
not as good as a for wood bees yeah no
neither did I anything it's decent
that it's like I don't really like the
main character no for some reason I
don't like I don't like any of the
characters I'll suck I'm really happy
that we're doing this because there's a
lot of anime series I'm figuring out to
watch and stuff that I feel I should
avoid now yeah so let's try to get
through a whole bunch of them like maybe
moving faster like Junie Tyson any of
you yes crappy fate/zero
oh that is like you know fate/zero has
like these epic characters fighting and
stuff with powers yeah this horrible
characters fighting with powers and it's
all signs of the zodiac oh wait wouldn't
wouldn't crappy fate/zero just be Oh
burn well come on be realistic it's true
yes that's like a Matt big game of
capture the flag that's how I look at
fade Apocrypha a huge capture the flag
game it's called read Tyson right yeah
the problem with this anime is let's say
12 minutes of every episode is devoted
to a character developing the character
and the character dies yeah that's for
the that's the girl like the girl don't
say that's the girl don't spoil any but
it's everyone it's not just one
character they do that episodically you
have this one carrot oh this is the main
character no dice oh this is maker guys
oh this is it dies there's no pretty
there's no no reason that I want to
continue watching this I don't care who
is the tree I disagree with you not
because I've seen the first episode so
far and I'm finding it to be quite an
entertaining action anime not anything
like spectacular but especially the
second episode I thought it was very
entertaining like it was over like so
fast I was like oh [ __ ] this is already
over which was a hint to me that I
thought that it was an entertaining
action well then then you already know
who dies in episode 3 that's how the
whole show works man so you're saying if
every episode they're gonna explore a
character than that characters gonna die
yeah yeah that's what happened in the
first 12 episodes what that's supposed
to mean that every character zero
development on living characters at this
point but that is still interesting
though because that's kind of like a
unique concept I'm open to it it's
interesting to consider a modern classic
let's not lie those words please classic
but I feel like it's a it's a nice
change of pace it's a it's like the
opposite of your show them protagonist
like oh no just connecting in are you
still there Mac I'm here okay alright so
I guess we move on to just because
yeah just because it's all right I think
nothing that grabs me but not bad yeah
can anyone relate to that no okay okay
it's not great
nothing grabbed me oh here's here's the
best one though
or me I I - well she go oh yeah goes yes
that one
which ones that oh yeah yeah that one is
good have you seen it cuz I don't want
to try to chop and don't try to
pronounce that don't watch it don't
watch it it is it is not the same as
skirt Nonaka it's right and if it was
terrible it is it is a better version
I like the difference between skirt
Nonaka and this is skirt Nonaka also had
cross-dressing and this one because the
guy felt like a creep because the simple
fact of him cross-dressing and then
getting younger girls and stuff here on
this sorry this has anyone seen kick eye
sensor yes I know I like it better than
the first season so far I have the
second season oh I haven't even seen the
first
season you haven't seen the first season
yet guys cat case Henson and Beyond is
the sequel to kick i sensing the first
season yet i think i'm watching the
first assumed it was new uh so what
happened in the first two it was in the
second episode was there a hospital
scene like the whole scene in on so they
they have like they set up the actual
whole world so it's like well they do
the beginning of every episode they do
that house the limbs look no but this
was like a whole like introducing for a
whole episode I think I just saw the
well it's not bad it's a pretty solid
anime Oh was the ending theme song the
best thing ever I don't know because I
keep getting interrupted oh so then why
don't you know that's weird
we can just we can just literally say
knucks is very much excited for this for
the season I can tell I'm excited I have
to talk three weeks worth right now no
but we got we got a charge of stop
interrupting each other guys because we
can't really help it always happens
well then some people are gonna be muted
Oh
anyway I I started watching the first
season because I was looking at
crunchyroll what their song assimil dubs
or whatever yeah but the new things by
the I must have been just gone on to the
first season because I saw okay I sense
and and just clicked on and they took me
to the first episode because I
definitely watched the first episode and
I thought it was interesting but not not
that it was kind of like Stephen King
needs ah
Lovecraft but in like a comedy setting
it was it's unique it is unique and
that's what I like about it it's not
specially either it's it's a lot more
episodic than I would like it to be by
the way fun fact in the orig original
translation to the Japanese was
Jerusalem's lot not hell's alums lot and
they got into trouble big trouble for
saying that Jerusalem has a bunch of
differ
you know races that hate each other know
what the Jerusalem's lot is actually the
name of a city fictional city that
Stephen King makes up in his works and
also known as Salem's Lot yep
well I assume that's what it's based off
of but a lot of people had the wrong
idea and they changed it to hell's alums
lot or they could have changed it
because of copyright issues mm-hmm yeah
possibly that's not what is never
impressed me though I didn't like the
first series you know after two episode
I was like yeah he's not gonna man to
none not not much is gonna happen this
and adopted it's a good time every
episodes a good time in its own right
and that it's nothing special nothing
and it doesn't amount to much right
although the final episode of the first
season was like an hour and a half long
movie which was oh nothing major there's
its own story I mean like a lot of it
there is an overarching plot but you
know for the most part doesn't really go
places but my favorite sequel this
season is Gintama who's watching that
anyone what got your vote if we got seen
online
oh I didn't really like the first season
so I'm not watching it hmm don't you
ever you have an interesting taste
you're not like a recon but you still
have a sort of contrary in taste in many
ways who me yes thank you
oh well in that case again so to you I I
don't believe in liking something cuz
it's hyped or liking something cuz it
isn't typed that's very not my
philosophy of Josh stuff he really wants
to talk about food war season 3
personally I never got into food or sell
not to because I need to go back and
watch the other two but I'm you guys if
you're watching share your opinions how
was the third season food wars is the
jojo's of cooking won't you so that
turns you off you suck
no easy scrap that's what means because
I've read the manga and trust me there's
only so much you can do with food and
eventually you can get bored but you
never get bored that's yeah well I
humbly disagree with you I believe you
can have a wonderful time with this
anime it's it's like the best Shonen
it's just the food except instead of
with quirks the only watching it for
those scenes then you know you'll be
entertained because all you're after is
those edgy scenes but no you're not
after nighttime you're after just some
substance from the story then you're
gonna go no I'm not not claiming their
substance I mean I'm claiming a shounen
you know it's sort of a cliche shown and
done really well with interesting
characters not a single character is
normal which is amazing and um you could
just fall in love with it I know you're
saying there's no grounding place no
every character is weird in their own
way and it's such a nice breath of fresh
air you don't have any like oh it's
AIT's under a cleat well you do have
it's under a cliche but it she's also
different in many ways that's cool yeah
I feel like it's like unique kind of
thing that I might want to get into
eventually oh I would totally give it a
chance I was even considering watching
it before and but I haven't gone through
yet but I probably will eventually well
you'll need to because we need to do in
every chef ever don't we yes throw on
Gordon Ramsay in there - who cares yeah
yeah although although what I really
want I will trade your food Wars any day
for more cage oh that's my truly I would
have to disagree with you Kay Joe's
great it's one of my favorite edgy
animes not that I like a lot of edgy
animes but K Jo's one of the best for
sure but yeah food Wars takes the cake
man watch Oh
yeah I'm genius but yeah watching
Twitter iike Otis well I noticed it's
unfortunate I mean I was finally gonna
agree with him that food Wars is awesome
oh well imagine who more sucks too much
food not enough boobs there's enough
boobs I mean we don't have that problem
here any of you watching um I lost it
there it is net Juno's Uzume that's
another one that sort of went under
everyone's radar that I think was pretty
pretty good I mean it's it's a comedy
and the romance and it's funny so I
guess it wins on all grounds no it's
basically about a girl who's a neat
again comedy based up a web manga oh
it's about 9:00 in the game then it's
about a girl who's a neat playing in
role-playing game as a guy and she
there's this other character that's
playing a girl but it's really another
guy but that other guy is like this
super impressive I'm dropping their guy
and they randomly bump into each other
in real life and whatever I think it's
funny oh no I would like that it's not
like a classic anime it's no recreate
errs but like no no I was gonna say not
like that guy the other one you remember
that guy and he's in that guild and then
that go you mean Netto gay it's not like
net one yeah it's a lot and that's a guy
is just more heist they're adults
they're like 30 I mean you know network
is just pandering yeah I I think it's
pretty pretty good and recon would agree
so it's good he's not here again I agree
though yeah I'll just say let's just say
he would agree because he's not here to
say no so
see oh well I don't agree on camera with
recon okay once the Red Cafe starts
recons wrong hole like stick entertain
yeah yeah yeah of course boys shout out
to recon by the way so now that he's not
here I assume none of you saw emote
little sisters all you need no no no I
know I have to tell you what this is
about it's wonderfulness you ready well
already so guy wakes up his little
sister is naked and sitting on him and
wants to have sex with him basically and
he says no not now so he goes into the
bathroom washes his face and wipes his
face off with his sister's bra goes
downstairs to eat breakfast his sister's
across the table also naked and made
food for him and he gets some food on
his face so what does she do to wipe off
his face she pulls her panties from an
alternate dimension to wipe his face
wait wait wait a minute this is amazing
this is the worst this is why people
hate otaku it was us cold moto what I'm
like you're the watch this it's the
cover and it's like a nice Street with
people walking down the street it's like
okay this looks like a pretty average
but it's not it's it's hell I'm time
watching this because you're telling me
it's a train wreck and I can now avoid
train wreck saying that this is
everything that's wrong with anime in
well I'm still waiting for the traps the
furries and lollies well we have lollies
the traps in the furries and then you
know problem solves we got a perfect
cringy anime if you want a persian of a
guy suddenly getting assisted then
there's chokotto sister that one is
though that was a good one related by
blood relay
by blood and he loves her okay then I'm
out I can do the whole not related by
blood well I would agree with you except
I love Dorian
that's like I was a little bit freaked
out with um elfin lead with like the
dude like what want to be with his
cousin you know
yeah but they like like okay but when
it's not the it's not the for focus of
the enemy it's like okay this is an
anime about cousins that love each other
no that is not elfin lead at all I know
that I mean I see the cousin is just one
of the people in the harem no you don't
make up the other chick too so yeah here
we come on the back recon hurt harem and
just came back in knitting oh geez or
not perfect you missed some good titles
your possible favorite anime of all time
Emoto sigh yo buddy
oh yeah okay no more I know about that
yeah he knows about that that was weird
how's it turn off does she actually say
I want to sleep with you or she just
like brother wake up like are they just
walking around naked are you making this
out to seem bad like is this battery I'm
making it out to seem worse than it is
but not that much like I can't imagine
her band like wake up we got to get it
on come on I'm ready my god he's waiting
and then be like no I gotta wash my face
no he just just washes his face the in
the bathtub she was in she makes him
milk and eggs
breast milk her breast milk that would
that - I forgot about that
you're right first of all are you saying
she's a lolly with breast milk what
second is washes his face in her bathtub
in the water she used yes that's correct
what it turns out that this didn't
really happen but whatever it's weird
enough that this is the maker these are
the main characters fantasies have to
watch it just to see whether you're
bullshitting or not I hope he's supposed
to be worse than like hand shakers and
air manga sense impressive honestly I
think hand shakers is probably the main
characters your stylist the main
characters a novelist and he wrote a
story about having a little sister that
does this [ __ ] so I thought that was
gonna be the actual series so first of
all buddy this he wrote this because he
is in love with his little sister and
notice I know manga sensei then it's
worse than era manga sensei like across
the board they're jokes fall flat in
that anime is not the anime community is
not such a cesspool of ridiculousness
and thought about like other [ __ ] lambda
s is a pretty cute anime I like blend s
yes nice a live comedy and it's cute
I mean basically it's a maid cafe where
every girl is sort of cosplaying I guess
as a different personality trait there's
one that plays the little sister
character so when everyone walks in on
EJ and there's the one boy the one girl
that's playing the tsundere and no
little sister I didn't know it so muy
the show is mowing the show's Maui and
the main character plays the sadistic
character so everyone walks it's like
you feel like and she's like this cute
little girl it's funny it's not again
it's nothing breaking any records here
it's
all blend s land us all right there oh
yeah it does look really cute and the
opening spoils the entire enemy so yeah
like it sounds like just like a time
passer basically it's like oh you need
something no yes pretty much it's just
basically a cafe with lollies that's
probably character to most if it was
real life sadly yeah I'm not one for
sadistic girls you guys watch that Cano
Cano huh
[Music]
you mean I don't know it has a K on it
man
case where is it when you copy and paste
stuff oh no I have not seen it actually
I got a little scared off
I saw shoujo eye and I saw all the girls
have animal years and I was like okay no
are you so scared of nickels not scared
of neck OHS it's just that looks like
it's the plot point use you're scared
are you like I guess hollows best waifu
just saying there's another good anime
it's where the girls are formed from
crystals yeah i forgot what it's cold
i also forgot to called again oh they're
not know i've been looking for it i
couldn't actually find it I saw part of
the first episode no no they're not
girls is that the one where they're
genderless yes that's the one yes yes
they're genderless that goes yeah just
like UQ holder going back to UQ holder
the main I was gonna say a female
character that's in love with the main
character that person is also genderless
which is weird
oh um no what was yes one of the main
characters could Kuro something you can
change gender yeah Jen its gender fluid
[Laughter]
I didn't even try
yeah no I did I don't like I don't like
3d but nice
and I may even don't like the 3d and if
you like the censoring it's good okay
it's a it's good concepts and unlike
Audion it's actually cool but an
interesting thing there is that there is
like an androgynous character like a
genderless character because it's sci-fi
like the character basically doesn't
it's just born without a gender however
in their life
eventually they choose a gender and then
because the character has a crush on a
guy the character becomes a girl starts
developing breasts and stuff so it's
like an interesting like one of those
don't show it to Pedro type anime no
it's fine man it's a fine the whole the
whole psyche no Kuni is like basically
there's 28 in a minute and gems in it
their code because that's what they're
born for me but then it's a they get
their assigned roles yeah I mean from
like when they grow up in it so you know
you're gonna be a fighter you're gonna
be a medic you know Wow what's it called
again what's it called Oh Oh sake yeah
it sounded very political to me I was
just like what oh I have to try this
thing to me yeah what I mentioned though
miles was talking about it in the chat
the Code Geass movie is coming in like
two days
on Saturday I believe the first recap
movie premieres so like we're gonna be
able to see if there's gonna be extra
footage if we're gonna get some news
about the sequel at some point maybe at
the end of the movie I'm looking forward
to knowing the code geass how it's been
we're not gonna get any [ __ ] news but
one can still hope
yeah I don't think you know I know I
know the mob it's getting taken out but
I don't think we're really gonna see
anything new until the last movie which
is gonna be basically yeah I agree with
you and also they're nice and the new
one I don't know I
we get something new because like they
need to keep people interested well we
got told the same thing about the
overload movies but we never got
anything new in the first they see you
on they say new as far as anime movies
and recaps they often mean new animation
like they'll reanimate certain parts it
doesn't necessarily mean there's gonna
be new narrative there is supposed to be
new scenes guys for Code Geass they did
say new scenes just you know yeah well
some random scenes are actually
important scenes that's a different
question
yeah the series also ke-wah-wah fufu
knee I don't know president
pronunciation sounds pretty dead-on all
that yeah it's about drunk during yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the wife yeah
yeah it's not it's not okay whatever
that's only three episodes no it's
basically about a husband and a wife and
the wife whenever she drinks alcohol
gets mega cute okay that sounds kind of
adorable yeah I mean it's called sake
gawe fufu so I'm guessing I'm guessing
no algata is not a big fan a big fan of
what no no definitely not no we're like
oh my gosh it's only interesting when
she's drunk what I will I will never be
like yeah I actually hate girls are like
that very much so okay look I don't know
if Emma feminism started as a quality I
think and then it sort of went somewhere
different so as far as what feminism is
supposed to be I'm a big fan exactly but
it sort of failed and now it's it's just
a nightmare everything's a nightmare
especially in America we're just a big
living nightmare as any of you guys
seemed awkward you said men and women
scene why'd you put man before women
[ __ ]
dynamic Court is a court what is that I
can't even see it's those tiny yeah it
looks like corn so tiny would
yeah that's cord right there it's tiny
don't see it don't know where it is
remember when I said if it's rated less
than 6 on my anime list run this is 5
okay one freaking fired first came out
it was rated lost less than 6 and that
was when it first came out death
provides one death parade was not rated
below a six I thought it was there have
definitely been moments in history of
time where a my anime list has rated
something too low I'm just sick sucks
there's a lot it's below 6 I don't
necessarily look at ratings you know
that religiously or anything but I do
think below 6 there's something off like
7 I've seen that I read like a seven ish
which I thought were really good say man
but yeah like a lung problem either
either people are mask skating on it for
some specific reason um no it's
controversial or something
or it's just not good no but I mean
there was was it the Kickstarter anime
under the dock that was rated a 6 point
something I think and those does pretty
good I think seems pretty good I don't
know what you're talking about so I have
no comment but it well well is what urea
noise how well is it rated on a tense
seven eight point thousand eight point
two four rating you realize wait to
continue decreasing as the fans keep
getting crazy oh absolutely
as the fans shoot more people they're
like I'm just gonna down rate you're
nice because I hate the fans well the
way it works everything goes down like
after right when it finishes airing it's
at its peak and then it just slowly you
know Ross that's how it is with
everything have you guys watched
and go in the city shut up oh yeah hey
okay listen
TenPoint oh I've watched the first
episode it was so [ __ ] bad don't come
to my workplace ever again like for the
first five minutes and I was like nope
boom escape five minutes guys
we gotta wrap this up we're over an hour
but I want to definitely thank you all
for some good animal discussion like I
said I've seen five or six enemies so
far the new ones this season and you've
given me some important ones to check
out including the ancient Magus bride or
models of the whales I mean those are
the two I'm gonna focus on checking out
same Aegis cause your eyes jump and
Trust Knox type anime no yeah well if I
close my eyes is going to be difficult
to watch but I will check it out and
I'll report back to let you know of what
I think one thanks for joining me
everyone in the chat thank you for the
suggestions and comments and caster for
life your stupid comments communist
greatest character and more biggest man
never again say stuff like that if you
haven't watched buh-buh-buh-buh no no no
not on here I don't need to watch
anything coming on
it's best before we go nuts since you're
back after few weeks so who are you what
do you do I am back and I'm nuts Taku on
YouTube I do a lot of anime stuff on a
lot of different anime sarcastic and
analysis and whatever we know the drill
aunty recon I don't care okay what
school tag called anyone I don't care
about ScrewAttack I don't care what in
that [ __ ] I will debate any of those
plebs at any point anywhere I have no
idea what you're talking about does
anyone else have any anyone is that man
I saw the subscription I don't know
buddy star ball but it doesn't matter
it's communist best
okay so yeah definitely guys check out
Knox's channel in the description
everyone's channel is in the description
because Knox and me are planning some
sexy sexy collabs very much that's next
week not that sexy
okay it's pretty sick but yes definitely
check that out now I got up to you
hi I'm now I gotta that was unexpected I
was expecting someone else to go recon
is not last you understand okay
yes yes I'm now God oh I don't wait to
go next and funny skits there you are
mm-hm
and on to the new guys gonna have to
check out your channel have never met
you before
it's been a pleasure yes very much so
that's all you go ahead no no recon okay
boys names recon ok recon no Picou and I
do them top tens so yeah what you
stopped reacting yes I did
no way he's done I moved on done
Ruggiero yeah
diversify your content but definitely
reactions are not interesting like in
terms of getting moved on so yeah
reactions my big news of the week is
noble reacted to my sarcastic fact video
[Music]
yeah and so and so marker yes I am so
much I mainly want to do anime related
content getting well manga related
content sorry getting people interested
more into manga because there is a lot
more content of mango out there than
anime I am currently got a coin oka
touchy
mango to anime comparison video out
there I will have some more content as
soon as I get this new camera that's in
the post and
yeah I'm you can find me doing VC on
anime of force discord so yeah yeah come
to the discord like a description want
to join the voice chats that knock soul
organises regularly with a bunch of
other cool people very fun times and
yeah guys thank you all everyone for
joining us in the discussion in the chat
hopefully this was helpful to you in
tears or if you're trying to decide what
to watch next leave a like if you like
rant cafe to let us all know and until
next time see us space cowboys recon
don't breathe in bro don't do it